hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be going to VidCon leaving really
soon actually so I'm gonna be there for
the next few days so from a little later
on uploads it's because I'm not the
biggest YouTube convention of the year
but before I leave
spectra Specter I'm gonna check out the
official trailer number one I'm excited
to see this Daniel Craig returning to
the role of bond I don't know if I got a
right spectro Specter Christoph Waltz is
in it
let's check this trailer suit you had no
authority
none Mexico City
[Music]
what were you doing that well I was
taking some overdue holiday
[Music]
so what's going on James they say you're
finished what do you say I think you're
just getting started
magnificent isn't she
zero to 60 and three point two seconds
nice yeah what do you have in mind when
we disappear
[Music]
tell me where he is is everywhere
you should go there you're crossing over
to a place over there is no mercy
[Music]
you're protecting someone get away from
me why should I trust you because right
now I'm your best chance of staying a
life damn right
this organization do you know what it's
called it's name is Spectre Spectre me
welcome James you came across me so many
times yes you never saw me
what took you so long
[Music]
this video what you want
leaving in the shadows 20 being I'm
always alone
I don't still just think about it
it was me James
[Music]
the author of all your pain
no no
[Music]
that looks really [ __ ] cool man that
looks more Bond ish and then bond debt
bondage James Bond doing bondage that
would be it experience but no and the
trailer has more of a Bond vibe than
we've gotten of any of the Daniel Craig
films so far this is gonna be a hard one
to top a lot of people consider Skyfall
one of the best Bond movies most people
consider Skyfall the best one of the
Daniel Craig films so I'm interested in
seeing this because I think this is
Daniel Craig's last one or he might be
signed on for two more I'm not sure but
this is gonna be a fun experience
because Skyfall is gonna be hard to top
it does feel very bond like the sets the
colors the settings of cinematography it
just feels so bond I mean some people
really like this type of Bond film
that's a little bit more real a little
bit more gritty a little bit more
elegant art you know the Bond movies are
kind of like I don't wanna say B movies
we're kind of like flashy B movies with
silly one-liners and gadgets and stuff
and some people want that back as other
people like this I'm hoping this filming
and gets a good hybrid of both and
Christoph Waltz is like one of the best
actors around [ __ ] love him he's one
of the stars of Django Unchained Django
Unchained one of my top 10 favorite
movies of all time however I am a little
letdown that they cut knitted cast him
only because Christoph Waltz as a bad
guy we've seen that before and you know
he can play villainous really well I
would have liked to have seen an actor
who's not known to play so many villains
but still I'm sure he's gonna do a great
job we're gonna get a sex scene between
Daniel Craig and Monica Bellucci Tim
doing that to her that barrel roll in
the helicopter that looked real I don't
know if that was CGI or not but I look
like a helicopter was really doing the
barrel roll that was pretty intense
going back to what I was talking about
with the gadgets and stuff like the new
car that bond is getting I'm hoping
that's like gadget filled because people
want the gadgets back even I do I hope
we really get that with the automobile
at least and yes Moriarty works for
Spectre I'm sure a bunch of people are
gonna be comment about that making
hilarious joke this movie seems like
it's having Bond flavor more than the
other ones a dead new Craig's been in we
got fast cars looks like we got some
cool weapons bond flying around hot Bond
girl memorable villain well at least
what looks like will be a memorable
villain cool stories still not losing
that sense of the personal touch that
the films have develop recently I think
it's gonna be a good flick anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope because if we get more
followers on there we can get even more
product placement sharknado 3 looks like
a good movie
Amanda blacksmith Ryan I watch your
channel every day so basically what I'm
trying to say is that you're the best on
my top 2 list is number 1 the real
rejects number 2
PewDiePie sorry
I know PewDiePie loves reactions he has
talked so highly of reactions that it's
funny that you'd make me number 1 over
him because PewDiePie he endorses
reaction know PewDiePie doesn't like
reactions he thinks they're a waste of
everyone's time
but PewDiePie I may have over 200,000
subs you may have liked over 30 million
subs but I'm coming for you PewDiePie
I'm coming for you and I'm bringing
Amanda with me she's a blacksmith she's
gonna make my weapons for me you know
I'm gonna do PewDiePie I'm gonna kill
myself
in front of you because I don't think I
can take you on thanks Amanda for the
moral support